[Music]
we're going to start with matt this hour
matt is in atlanta georgia hi matt how
are you
good dave how are you better than i
deserve sir what's up in your world
uh not much um i've got a question for
you in regards to
selling a house
uh me and my wife are in the process of
selling that we have about
two hundred and fifty thousand dollars
in equity yay and we are playing yes we
are planning to move to my parents house
for
two to five years why
uh they are
in the process of buying a house in
florida and not quite ready to sell
their
main
uh property
so they won't be there while you live
there
they will not
but they're letting you live there for
for free
correct
and then you're going to buy it later
correct
or somewhere else we're not quite sure
how that will work out so it's part of
the deal they're not making you buy this
house eventually
no we're not okay
is not
forced by um
but we want we want that equity of our
house to continue to grow
um right now my wife and i
are still working through baby step two
we have about thirty thousand dollars
left to pay off
um
and just trying to decide if we
continue to use
the equity in our house to pay off our
our debts or put that money towards
something that can continue to grow for
us did i hear 35 000 clears it and you
got 250
correct okay that's a no-brainer do that
for sure then we still park the rest of
it for the future house purchase right
correct okay i got to go back to the
deal because i'm struggling
okay i need a little bit of detail here
um so mom and dad are moving out of
their house
and you're going to move into it and
live there free
for three to five years
correct where are mom and dad moving
they are moving to florida
what are they going to live in
a rental are they buying or
they're they're buying a house in
florida have oh i actually already
bought it why are they not selling you
this house now
i don't quite know i wouldn't want to
buy this house
we're just doing this my wife and i to
help them
a little bit through the process of
whether or not they want to move to
florida
uh
for the foreseeable future or future or
if they want to move back to georgia
and and live in their house how old are
you
uh 30 years old a little old to be doing
house sitting
yeah i agree
this is weird especially for five years
i think they need to paint or get off
the ladder
if they're going to florida they need to
sell their house and you need to go buy
a house
yeah here's the problem here's the
problem with your deal okay it's a nice
thing for them and it sounds good
because you're getting to live there for
free right
right but the problem is that in the
next five years houses will have gone up
in value and you will have been out of
the market that whole time while you
house it for parents who are indecisive
right
i don't think this is a good deal for
you
okay i want you to be a homeowner
with i mean and you got 250 or 215 000
after we paid off your debt
so if you don't want to buy this house i
would go buy a different house but you
sold your house for the sole purpose of
doing this deal
yes and and my wife and i do love the
property um
we probably would purchase
i'm sorry i should say again
my wife and i it's a family property we
love the property
if if the opportunity arises and we can
buy the house for my parents i would i
would do so i was just talking to a guy
a minute ago who said he didn't want to
buy this house
where did he go it's not for it's not
for sale right now
we're we we're i'm not 100 sold on it
that we would purchase this house if it
was on the market it's quite a bit out
of our budget
um
but you know the property is great and
what's the property worth
uh probably a hundred uh sorry 1.5
million
yeah it is out of you well i don't know
what do you make a year what's your
household income
uh we make uh 120. yeah it's out of your
budget okay what would they what would
they sell it to you for would it be
value
it would uh they they bought it at a an
auction and
um
it's
they got a great deal out of it
um if we were to buy it it would have to
be
kind of a non-interest uh
long-term buyout of the home
which i'm not okay here's what here's if
you're going to go forward with this
deal here's the only way you don't get
burnt
um i still think the deal is squarely
because it sounds so like indecisive
and you're getting in the middle of
other people's being indecisive and
that's always a bad that's like playing
in the traffic
okay so um
the uh but what i do want you to do is i
want them to give you a written
option to purchase
on this property
today
a right to buy
a set price
that you makes you smile
okay and i want you to record that
option at the courthouse as a lien on
the title
do this legally like this was done with
strangers
okay okay and that's how you do business
with family too by the way not because
we think family's gonna screw us but
because we half but do stuff because we
think they're not gonna screw us and
then they do so then you get all you do
business right okay but you need to lock
in the price at today's values
and makes you smile and if that's a
million dollar purchase for a million
and a half house
do that
live there three or four years at least
then you're not the all the other
properties around you in life are not
going up in value and you get you lose
all of that appreciation in the next
five years while you're a glorified
house sitter
right so lock in can you do that
i could do that yeah that's otherwise
you're burnt man you're burnt on you're
losing all the appreciation of the next
five years
and then park your money in some mutual
funds with a smart investor pro after
you pay off your debts and have your
emergency fund in place yeah and even
then if you purchase it for a million he
might have to take out a mortgage for
700 000 which may be way beyond might be
but it might not be but if he's got an
option for five years
or a right to you know first right
they're living there for free for five
years they can save up like crazy people
while their other money there we go
there we go yeah now you take 120 000
and you take
what 2 2500 bucks a month that was your
normal house payment or whatever and you
go bonkers and pile up cash that's 30
000 bucks a year plus growth and you do
that that's another that's another 150
200 000 to put on this now we're
starting to get there yeah so you get a
deal locked in and you use this time to
save like crazy then you get there and
you don't even have to do a mortgage
with them i wouldn't do a mortgage with
them long term i don't recommend that
even if it's zero percent but i would
get a deeply discounted price from them
gladly
and lock that in in a formal option
today don't do this deal
if you don't because you're going to get
burnt here man this is going to leave
you out of the market for five years and
that's not a good place to be real
estate is not crashing during this five
years it's going up